the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we're moving on from theoretical
things from the mean value theorem to
the introduction to the what's going to
occupy us for the whole rest of the
course which is integration so in order
to enter into introduce that subject I
need to introduce for you a new notation
which is called differentials I'm going
to tell you what a differential is and
we'll get used to using it over over
time if you have a function which is y
equals f of X then the differential of Y
of Y so is going to be denoted dy and
it's by definition F prime of X DX so
here's the notation and because Y is
really equal to F sometimes we also call
it the differential of F so it's also
called the differential of F
now that's the notation and it's the
same thing as what happens if you
formally just take this DX act like it's
a number and divide it into dy so it
means the same thing as this statement
here and this is the more or less the
libel it's not lighting its
interpretation of derivatives of a
derivative as a ratio of these so-called
differentials it's a ratio of what are
known as infinitesimal x' now this is a
kind of a vague notion this this little
this little bit here being a an
infinitesimally so it's sort of like an
infinitely small quantity and Leibniz
perfected the idea of dealing with these
intuitively and subsequently
mathematicians use them all the time
they're way more effective than the
notation that Newton used you might
think that notations are a small matter
but they allow you to think much faster
sometimes when you have the right names
and the right symbols for everything and
in this case it made a very big
difference Leibniz notation was adopted
on the continent and Newton dominated in
Britain and as a result the British fell
behind by one or two hundred years in
the development of calculus it was
really a serious matter so it's really
well worth your while to get used to
this idea of ratios and it comes up all
over the place both in this
class and also in multivariable calculus
it's used in in many contexts so first
of all just to go a little bit easy
we'll illustrate it by its use in linear
approximations which we've already done
the picture here which we've drawn a
number of times is that you have some
function and here's a value of the
function and it's coming up like that
all right so here's our function and we
go forward a little increment to a place
which is DX further along the idea of
this notation is that DX is going to
replace the symbol Delta X which is the
change in X and we won't think too hard
about well this is a small quantity this
is a small quantity we're not going to
think too hard about what that means now
similarly if you see how much we've gone
up well this is kind of low so so small
bit here so this distance here is
previously we called it Delta Y but now
we're just going to call it a DA dy ok
so DX dy replaces Delta Y all right so
this is the change in level of the
function and will represent it
symbolically this way very frequently
it's just saves a little bit of notation
for the purposes of this we'll be doing
the same things we did with Delta X and
Delta Y but this is the way that live
and it's thought of it and he would just
have drawn it with this so this distance
here is DX and this distance here is dy
so for an example of linear
approximation
we'll say what's the 64 point one say to
the 1/3 power approximately equal to now
I'm going to carry this out in this in
this new notation here the function
involved is X to the 1/3 and then it's
differential dy now I want to use this
rule to get used to it because this is
what we're going to be doing all of
today is we're differentiating or taking
the differential of Y so that is going
to be just the derivative that's
one-third X to the minus 2/3 DX and now
I'm just going to fill in exactly what
this is at x equals 64 which is the
natural place to close by where it's
easy to do the evaluations we have Y is
equal to 64 to the 1/3 which is just 4
and how about dy well so this is a
little bit more complicated put it over
here so dy is one-third times 64 to the
minus 2/3 DX and that is one-third times
a 1/16 DX which is 1 over 48 DX
and now I'm going to work out what 64
the whatever it is here this strange
fraction I just want to be very careful
to explain to you one more thing which
is that we're using X is equal to 64 and
so we're thinking of X plus DX is going
to be 64 point one all right so that
means that DX is going to be 1/10 all
right so that's the increment that we're
interested in
and now I can carry out the
approximation the approximation says
that 64 point 1 to the 1/3 is well it's
approximately what I'm going to call y
plus dy because really the dy that I'm
determining here is determined by this
linear relation dy is equal to 148 DX
and so this is only approximately true
because what's really true is that this
is equal to y plus Delta Y in our
previous notation so this is in disguise
what this is equal to and that's only
approximately equal to what the what the
linear approximation would give you so
really even though I wrote dy is this
increment here what it really is if DX
is exactly that is it's the amount that
you would go up if you went straight up
the tangent line so I'm not going to do
that because that's not what people
write and that's not even what they
think right they're really thinking of
both DX and dy is being infinitesimally
small and here we're going to the to the
finite level and and and doing it so
that you know this is just just
something you have to live with is that
a little ambiguity in this notation all
right so this is the approximation and
now I can just calculate these numbers
here Y at this value is 4 and dy as I
said is 148 DX and that turns out to be
4 plus 1 over 480 because DX is a tenth
so that's approximately four point zero
zero two and that's our approximation
now let's just compare it to to our
previous notation this will serve as a
review of if you like of linear
approximation but what I want to
emphasize is that these things are
supposed to be the same
just that it's really the same thing
it's just a different notation for the
same thing I remind you the basic
formula for linear approximation is that
f of X is approximately F of a plus F
prime of a times X minus a and we're
applying it in the situation that a is
64 and f of X is X to the one-third and
so F of a which is f of 64 is of course
4 and F prime of a which is a to the
right 1/3 a to the minus 2/3 is in this
in our case one sixteenth note one forty
eight okay that's the same calculation
as before and then our relationship
becomes X to the one-third is
approximately equal to four plus one
over 48 times X minus a which is 64
so look every every single number that
I've written over here has a
corresponding number for this for this
other method and now if I plug in the
value we happen to want which is the 64
point 1 this would be 4 plus of 48 times
1/10 which is just the same thing we had
before so again same answer same method
new notation well now I get to use this
notation in a you know in a more in a
novel way so again here's the notation
this notation of differential the way
I'm going to use it is in discussing
something called anti derivatives again
this is a new notation now but it's also
a new ideas one that we haven't
discussed yet namely the notation that I
want to describe here is what's called
the integral of G of X DX and I'll
denote that by a function capital G of X
so as you start with a function G of X
and you produce a function capital G of
X which is called the antiderivative of
G
notice there's a differential sitting in
here this symbol this guy here is called
an integral sign or an integral or and
that's that this whole thing is called
an integral and another name for the
antiderivative of G is the indefinite
integral of G and I'll explain to you
why it's indefinite in just very shortly
here well so let's carry out some
examples
basically what I'd like to do is as many
examples along the lines of all the
derivatives that we derived at the
beginning of the course in other words
in principle you want to be able to
integrate as many things as possible
we're going to start out with the
integral of sine X DX that's a function
whose derivative is sine X so what
function would that be cosine X - right
it's negative cosine X all right so
negative cosine X differentiated gives
you sine X so that is an antiderivative
of sine and it satisfies this property
so this function capital G of x equals
negative cosine X has the property that
it's derivative is sine X on the other
hand if you differentiate a constant you
get zero so this answer is what's called
indefinite because you can also add any
constant here and the same thing will be
true so C is constant and as I said that
the the integral is called indefinite so
that's the next one nation for this
modifier in front of the integral its
indefinite because we actually didn't
specify a single function we don't get a
single answer whenever you take the
antiderivative of something it's
ambiguous up to a constant
next let's do some other standard
functions from our repertoire we have
the integral of x to the a DX some power
the integral of a power and if you think
about it what you should be
differentiating is one power larger than
that but then you have to divide by 1
over a plus 1 in order that the
differentiation be correct right so this
just is the fact that D by DX of X to
the a plus 1 or maybe I should even say
it this way maybe I'll do it in
differential notation D of X to the a
plus 1 is equal to a plus 1 X to the a
DX so if I divide that through by a plus
1 then I get the relation above and
because this is ambiguous up to a
constant it could be any additional
constant added to that function
now the identity that I wrote down below
is correct
but this one is not always correct
what's the exception yeah ables
equals negative one so this one is okay
for all a but this one fails because we
divided by zero when is equal to
negative one so this is only true when a
is not equal to negative one
and in fact of course what's happening
when a is equal to zero as you're
getting zero you differentiate the
constant so there's a third case that we
have to carry out which is the
exceptional case namely the integral of
DX over X and this time if we just think
back to what our so what we're doing is
thinking backwards here which is a very
important thing to do in in math at all
stages we got all of our formulas now
we're reading them backwards and so this
one you may remember is the natural log
of X the reason why I want to do this
carefully and slowly now is right now I
also want to write the more standard
form which is presented so first of all
of course we have to add a constant and
please don't put the parentheses here
the parentheses go there okay but
there's another formula hiding in the
woodwork here behind this one which is
that you can also get the correct
formula when X is negative and that
turns out to be this one here so I'm
treating the case X positive as being
something that you that you know but
let's check the case X negative in order
to check the case X negative I have to
differentiate the logarithm of the
absolute value of x in that case and
that's the same thing again for X
negative as the derivative of the
logarithm of negative x that's the
formula when X is negative
and if you carry that out what you get
and you'll put this over here is well
it's the chain rule it's one over
negative x times the derivative with
respect to X of negative x so see that
there are two minus signs there's a
minus X in the denominator and then
there's the derivative of minus X in the
numerator that's just negative one this
part is negative one so this is negative
one over negative x which is 1 over X so
the the the negative signs cancel if you
just keep track of this in terms of log
negative x and its graph that's a
function that looks like this 4x
negative and it's derivative is 1 over X
I claim and if you just look at it a
little bit carefully you see that the
slope is always negative right so here
the slope is negative so it's it's it's
it's going to be below the axis and in
fact it's getting steeper and steeper
negative as we go down so it's and it's
getting less and less negative as we go
horizontally so it's going like this
which is indeed the graph of this
function 4x negative again X negative
all right
all right so that's a one other standard
formula and you know very quickly very
often we won't put the absolute value
signs we'll only consider the case X
positive here but I just want you to
have the tools to to do it in case we
want to use we want to handle both
positive and negative X now let's do two
more examples the integral of secant
squared X DX these are supposed to get
you to remember all of your
differentiation formulas is standard one
so this one integral of secant squared
DX is what tan X and here we have plus C
alright and then the last one a couple
of this type would be let's see I should
do at least this one here square root of
1 minus x squared this is another
notation by the way which is perfectly
acceptable notice I've put the DX in the
numerator and the function in the
denominator here so this one turns out
to be sine inverse X and finally let's
see about the integral of DX over 1 plus
x squared that one is tan inverse x
for a little while because you're
reading these things backwards and
forwards you'll find this happens to you
on exams it gets slightly worse for a
little while you will anti-differentiate
when you meant to differentiate and
you'll differentiate when you meant to
anti-differentiate don't get too
frustrated by that but you know
eventually you'll get them you'll get
them squared away and it actually helps
to do a lot of practice with with with
anti differentiations because or
integrations as they're sometimes called
because that will solidify your
remembering all the differentiation
formulas all right so last bit of
information that I want to emphasize
before we go on to more complicated
examples is this I it's obvious because
the differential of a constant is zero
that the that the antiderivative is
ambiguous up to a constant but it's very
important to realize that this is this
is the only ambiguity that there is so
the last thing that I want to tell you
about is uniqueness of anti derivatives
up to a constant the theorem is the
following
theorem is if F prime equals G prime
then F equals G so f of X equals G of X
plus a constant
that means not only that these are anti
derivatives all these things with these
plus Caesar are anteaters but these are
the only ones which is very reassuring
and that's a kind of uniqueness although
its uniqueness up to a constant it's
acceptable to us now the proof of this
is very quick but this is a fundamental
fact the proof is the following if f
prime is equal to G prime then if you
take the difference between the two
functions its derivative which of course
is f prime minus G prime is equal to
zero hence f of X minus G of X is a
constant now this is a key fact very
important fact we deduced it last time
from the mean value theorem it's not a
small matter it's a very very important
thing it's the basis for calculus it's
the reason why calculus makes sense if
we didn't have the fact that the
derivative is zero implied that the
function was constant we would be done
we would have there were calculus would
be just useless for us the point is the
rate of change is supposed to determine
the function up to this starting value
so this conclusion is very important and
we already checked it last time this
conclusion and now just by algebra I can
rearrange this to say that f of X is
equal to G of X
plus a constant all right now oh maybe I
should leave differentials up here
because I want to illustrate all right
so let's go on to some trickier slightly
trickier integrals here's an example of
the integral of say X cubed times X to
the fourth plus two to the fifth power
DX this is a function which you actually
do know how to integrate because we
already have a formula for all powers
namely the integral of X to the a is is
equal to this and even if it were a
negative power we could do it so it's
it's okay on the other hand to expand
the fifth power here is quite a mess and
this is a just a very very bad idea
there's another trick for doing this
that evaluates this much more
efficiently and it's the only device
that we're going to learn now for for
integrating integration actually is much
harder than differentiation symbolically
it's quite difficult and occasionally
impossible and so we have to go about it
gently but for the purposes of this unit
we're only going to use one method which
is very good that means whenever you see
an integral either you'll be able to
divine immediately what the answer is or
you'll use
this method so this is it the trick is
called the method of substitution
and it is tailor-made for the notion of
differentials so tailor-made for
differential notation the idea is the
following I'm going to define a new
function and it's the sort of messiest
function that I see here it's U is equal
to X to the fourth plus two and then I'm
going to take its differential and what
I discover if I look at its formula is
and the rule for differentials which is
right here
it's formula is what 4x cubed DX now lo
and behold with these two quantities I
can substitute I can plug in to this
integral and I will simplify it
considerably so how does that happen
well this integral is the same thing is
the same thing as well really I should
combine it the other way so let me move
this over so there are two pieces here
and this one is U to the fifth and this
one is 1/4 D u so that makes it the
integral of U to the fifth do you
divided by four and that's relatively
easy to integrate that is just a power
so let's see it's I can it's just a
twentieth you to the whoops
not a twentieth of the antiderivative of
U to the fifth is U to the sixth with a
one-sixth so it's one over twenty four U
to the sixth plus C now that's not the
answer to the question it's almost the
answer the question why isn't it the
answer it isn't the answer because now
the answers expressed in terms of U
whereas the problem was posed in terms
of this variable X so we must change
back to our variable here and we do that
just by writing it in so it's 124 X to
the fourth plus 2 to the power 6 plus C
right and this is the end of the problem
yeah question
the president can you see it directly
yeah and we're going to talk about that
in just one second okay now I'm going to
do one more example and illustrate this
method well here's another example the
integral of x DX over the square root of
1 plus x squared now here's another
example now the method of substitution
leads us to the idea U is equal to 1
plus x squared D u is equal to 2 X DX
etc it takes about as long as this other
problem did to figure out what's going
on it's a very similar sort of thing you
end up integrating u to the minus 1/2
right it leads to the integral of U to
the minus 1/2 do you write everybody
seeing where this where this however
there is a slightly better method okay
so recommended method and I call this
method advanced guessing
what advanced guessing means is that
you've done enough of these problems
that you can see two steps ahead and you
know what's going to happen so the
advanced guessing leads you to believe
here you had a power minus one-half here
you have the differential of the things
so it's going to work out somehow and
the advanced guessing allows you to
guess that the answer should be
something like this 1 plus x squared to
the one-half so this is your advanced
guess and now you just differentiate it
and see whether it works well here it is
it's 1/2 1 plus x squared to the minus
1/2 times 2x that's the chain rule here
which sure enough gives you x over
square root of 1 plus x squared so we're
done and so the answer is square root of
1 plus x squared plus C
let me illustrate this further with
another example I strongly recommend
that you do this because but you have to
get used to it so here's another example
e to the 6 X DX my advanced guess is e
to the 6 X and if I check what I
different when I differentiate it I get
6 e to the 6 X that's the derivative and
so I know that the answer so now I know
what the answer is it's 1/6 e to the 6 X
plus C now ok you could it's also ok ok
but slow to use a substitution to use U
is equal to 6 X then you're going to get
D U is equal to 6 DX dot dot it's going
to work it's just a waste of time
all right well I'm going to give you a
couple more examples so how about this
one X times e to the minus x squared DX
what's the guess anybody have a guess
well you've been all suppressed so I
don't I don't want you to bother yeah go
ahead yeah so you're already one step
ahead of me because this is too easy
I just when they get more complicated
you just want to make this this guess
here so various people have said a half
and they understand that there's a half
going on here but let me just show you
what happens okay if you make this guess
and you differentiate it what you get
here is e to the minus x squared times
the derivative of negative 2x so that's
minus 2x sorry negative x squared so
it's minus 2x so now you see that you're
off by a factor of not two but negative
two all right so a number of you were
saying that so the answer is minus 1/2 e
to the minus x squared plus C and I can
guarantee you having watched this on
various problem sets name that people
who don't write this out
I'll make arithmetic mistakes in other
words there is a limit to how much
people can think ahead and guess
correctly another way of doing it by the
way is simply to write this thing in and
then fix the coefficient by doing the
differentiation here that's perfectly
okay as well alright one more example
we're going to integrate sine X cosine X
DX
so what's a good guess for this one
someone suggested sine squared X so
let's try that over - well we'll get the
coefficient in just a second so sine
squared X if I differentiate it I get
twice sine X cosine X so that's off by a
factor of two so the answer is 1/2 sine
squared X
but now I want to point out to you that
there's another way of doing this
problem it's also true that if you
differentiate cosine squared X you get
two cosine x times minus sine X all
right so another answer is that the
integral of sine X cosine X DX is equal
to negative 1/2 cosine squared X plus C
so what is going on here what's the
problem with this pardon me into those
intervals are unique that's part of the
extensors still have to be the same
okay what do you think see if you add
them together you get see well actually
that's almost right that's not what you
want to do though you don't want to add
them you want to subtract them okay so
let's see what happens when you subtract
them I'm going to ignore the C for the
time being I get sine squared X 1/2 sine
squared X minus minus 1/2 cosine squared
X so the difference between them we hope
to be 0 but actually of course it's not
0 what it is is it's 1/2 sine squared
plus cosine squared which is 1/2 it's
not 0 it's a constant so it's really
going on here is that these two formulas
are the same but you have to understand
how to interpret them the two constants
here's a constant up here there's a
constant C 1 associated to this one
there's a different constant C 2
associated to this one and this family
of functions for all possible C ones and
all possible C 2's are this is the same
family of functions now what's the
relationship between C 1 and C 2
well if you do the subtraction C 1 minus
C 2 has to be equal to 1/2 they're both
constants but they differ by 1/2
so this this explains when you're
dealing with families of things they
don't have to look the same and there
are lots of trig functions which look a
little different so there there can be
several formulas that actually are the
same you it's hard to check that they're
actually the same you need some trig
identities to do it okay let's do one
more example here
here's another one
now you may be thinking a lot of people
are thinking it's got a log in it if
you're experienced you actually can read
off the answer just the way there were
several people were shouting out the
answers when we when we were doing the
rest of these problems but you do need
to relax because in this case now this
is definitely not true in general when
we do integrals but for now when we do
integrals they'll all be manageable and
there's only one method which is
substitution and in the substitution
method you want to go for the trickiest
part and substitute for that so the
substitution that I propose to you is
that this should be you shall be log X
and the advantage that that has is that
its differential is simpler than itself
so D U is equal to DX over X remember we
use that in logarithmic differentiation
to write so now we can express this
using the substitution and what we get
is the integral of so I'll divide the
two parts here it's 1 over log X and
then it's DX over X and this part is 1
over U and this part is D U so it's the
integral of D u oppa divided by U and
that is log u plus C
which altogether if I put back in what
what you is is log log X plus and now we
see some some more uglier things in fact
technically speaking we could take the
absolute value here right and then this
would be absolute values there all right
so this is the type of example where I
really would recommend that you actually
use the substitution at least for now
all right tomorrow we're going to be
doing differential equations and we're
going to review for the test I'm going
to give you a handout telling you just
exactly what's going to be on the test
so see you tomorrow